welcome back to new rockstars i'm tommy
bechtolden spider-man
miles morales on the ps4 and ps5 is
littered with
easter eggs and hidden references to
previous games spider-man into the
spider-verse
and the broader mcu at large i'm going
to run through as many of the cool
details and comic references as we could
find
and i should say spoiler warning some of
these come up later in the game so if
you haven't finished it yet or if you're
like me and just have thumbs that are
too big to play a video game
and you have to watch your little nephew
play obviously there's a lot of the same
references as the 2018 ps4 games such as
daredevil's losses or sanctum sanctorum
for instance this game does a great job
of adding to the legacy of that game
well
including the star of into the spider
versus miles morales so i mean i think
that's super exciting and an interesting
take to bring forward into the game
miles morales is a super popular
character and giving him the video game
treatment and hopefully pretty soon the
movie treatment is definitely the way to
go
we get some of miles unique personality
and background throughout the game like
how you can make him salsa dance and how
he does that iconic cringe finger guns
from spider-man 3 but his fingers this
time are charged with bioelectric power
so a little less cringey a little more
singing
oh and they even referenced tom holland
holding the ferry together with spider
webs in spider-man homecoming pretty
cool
you know what they say baby in these
video games it's all about locations
locations
locations avengers tower is still in the
same spot as the previous game
forever tempting us with the possibility
of other avengers or superheroes showing
up get off your ass hawkeye
and crying out loud what are you doing
shooting arrows starting your own cell
phone app good lord
news since 2018 there's a massive black
lives matter girl in the background and
completing submissions will get you a
black and yellow suit which are the
signature colors of the black lives
matter
iconography in the first spider-man you
could visit a cemetery in harlem where
you could pay your respects to
ben parker's grave rip uncle ben
you was a bad one this is back in miles
morales world with more graves to get
misty over
i'm gonna miss everybody aunt may
officer davis speaking of touching
memorial stan lee made a cameo in the
2018 game as
mick the short order cook you can return
to the same diner where peter and mj
bumped into mick and see a giant statue
outside of the diner in his honor the
inscription reads
dedicated with love to the man who
nourished the hearts minds and souls
of true believers everywhere excelsior
what a great in-universe tip of the hat
to the great stan lee
let's talk developer details insomniac
games put a lot of great developer
details and nods to the greater marvel
universe they snuck their own logo in as
a chandelier in the mall during the
fight with rhino getting back to
tear-jerking real-life tributes the
developers put a tribute of the recently
passed black panther actor
chadwick boseman at the end of credits
once you finish the game there's also a
bozeman way
street in the game in miles morales one
of the time capsules players can find
contains the green and black wakandan
flag miles social media handle is
k l y n spider 42 with the number
referring to jackie robinson's jersey
number jackie robinson was the player
who integrated baseball
and he's the hero of miles morales who
is kind of integrating the spider verse
so i i think that was really clever
although if your handle has spider in it
you're not really keeping a secret
identity are you in a later mission we
find out that fisk uses vanessa the love
of fisk's life and the only person he
actually cares about as his password
lame set a reminder to delete all of my
passwords that contain the words
rebecca at the start of the game you can
look next to miles's bedside and spot an
issue of the amazing fantasy number 15
featuring spider-man's first appearance
from marvel comics
mint copies of the original comic sell
for over a million
dollars so is miles a secret millionaire
the same comic was in peter's bedroom in
the previous game so maybe they should
both just retire but that's not having
great responsibility to go along with
the great powers so
uncle ben would not approve all right
let's talk character references
miles finds two ticket stubs for a 2015
concert of dazzler and lila chaney
dazzler
is the mutant alison blair and lila
chaney is a mutant musician who can
teleport sounds like a fun concert
miles also comes across a computer
graphics card with handwriting on it
that says mastermind x4 mutant villain
mastermind first appeared in x-men issue
4.
clearly the two easter eggs are proof
that we'll get mutants in the mcu
confirmed no doubt about it a little bit
of doubt about it for non-mutant
character references there's rocks in
terminal with descriptions of criminal
associates the first is for a cat
burglar who's recently retired black cat
who appeared in the first game and all
those side missions and extra content
the second is the leader of a bunker
gang tombstone who peter also tangled
with in the first game the last person
mentioned
is a reference to miles uncle aaron aka
prowler on a tape recorder daily bugle
head honcho j
jonah jameson can be heard complaining
about spider-man and where
will it all end spider woman spider punk
spider pig who all of us spider heads
know
is a legit crime fighter voiced by john
mullini that's a
crazy thing to say speaking of into the
spider-verse references players can get
the
vibe the verse suit mod which will
recreate the life-stuttered 24 frames
per second hand animation feel of the
movie there's also the bam pow wham
visor mod that adds comic book style
onomatopoeia when you attack enemies
that really drive the cartoon feel home
miles can also hit the iconic reclining
while
falling pose from the movie those that
pre-order the game or get to a certain
level can unlock the spider-verse suit
hilariously the game has the same exact
fall animation as the movie does when
miles falls from heights
let's talk cutscene during a flashback
in which young miles visits the science
center
miles bumps into peter parker
accompanied by doc ock himself otto
octavius speaking of cameos the
post-credits scene from 2018's
spider-man game showed harry osborne
being treated for ashtoren's syndrome
with the use of symbiote while his
father norman looked on the mid-credits
scene of miles morales expands on that
moment but from harry's perspective
inside the green tank we see aquariums
that look like they're holding reptiles
which makes sense since his doctor is
kirk connors aka the lizard norman
osborne green goblin harry osborn venom
and kurt connor's lizard means we're
halfway to a sinister six
and i'm here for that comment below if
you want me or new rockstars to cover
more gaming topics talk gaming and all
the other nerdy topics on new rockstars
discord by becoming a patron
at patreon.com new rockstars you can
even make sunday football picks with me
and a group of other guys that are super
fun
there's a prize at the end of the season
you're gonna have to hurry up though
because we got a three week head start
on you follow me at tommy bechtold
follow new rockstars and subscribe for
more great breakdowns of the things you
love
good day
[Music]
you